Er kam vor fünf Jahren nach Deutschland.
Zusammen mit seinem jüngeren Bruder floh
Tarek Khouli vor dem Krieg in Syrien
– im Gepäck sein Diplom.
Denn ganz von vorne
wollte er nicht anfangen.
In seiner Heimat hatte er schon einen Beruf
gelernt und bei dem wollte er bleiben.
2009 … Ich habe angefangen
mit [der] Ausbildung.
Seitdem habe ich bis jetzt gearbeitet
in diesem Bereich.
Ich habe [bin] als
Industriemechaniker ausgebildet.
Und dort habe ich in einer Firma gearbeitet,
die Kühlschränke herstellt.
Hier macht er Vakuumsauger und
profitiert von seiner Ausbildung in Syrien.
Er liebt seinen Beruf.
Deswegen wollte er
unbedingt seine Qualifikationen
in Deutschland anerkennen lassen.
Der Weg bis dahin war nicht einfach:
Von einem Amt zum anderen
wurde er geschickt.
Schließlich kam Hilfe von der
Industrie- und Handelskammer.
Dort[hin] habe ich alle Dokumente
gebracht und gezeigt einfach.
Dann … Die haben mir gesagt,
das geht auch.
Vor diesem Problem stehen viele
Migranten in Deutschland und die,
die noch hierher kommen wollen.
2018 haben fast 30.000 Menschen
einen Antrag auf Anerkennung
ihrer erworbenen Ausbildung gestellt.
Eine große Herausforderung bei den
Anerkennungsverfahren ist tatsächlich
das Herausfinden des sogenannten
deutschen Referenzberufs,
wo ich meine Anerkennung stellen kann.
Wenn ich aber aus einem Drittstaat komme,
dann habe ich die Situation,
dann brauche ich die Anerkennung
zwingend für die Einreise.
Fachkräfte werden in Deutschland
dringend benötigt.
Unternehmen wie das von Udo Werner sind
auf Arbeitsmigranten angewiesen.
Deshalb ist er froh, Industriemechaniker wie
Tarek Khouli bei sich zu haben.
Jemand, der so ’ne Anerkennung bekommen
hat, der kommt ja ganz anders hierhin.
Der hat ein anderes Selbstwertgefühl.
Und der ist dann einfach hoch motiviert,
hier zu arbeiten, noch mehr zu lernen,
sich weiterzubilden,
auch die Sprache zu lernen.
Das sehen wir an dem Tarek sehr deutlich.
Aber der Anfang war für ihn auch nicht leicht.
Er musste erst einmal die
deutsche Technik kennenlernen.
Doch jetzt arbeitet er selbstständig.
Ich bin … Ohne Arbeit bin ich tot.
Ich kann nicht zu Hause sitzen.
Ich habe [war] immer gewohnt …
Von [Seit] Anfang von meinem Leben
habe ich gearbeitet
und bis jetzt habe ich gearbeitet.
Das deutsche Diplom
motiviert den 26-Jährigen.
Jetzt will er seine Deutschkenntnisse noch
verbessern und den
Meisterabschluss machen.